[Musique]
tremblement terre assassinats politiques
pauvreté extrême corruption la misère
d'haïti semble sans fin et ça ne date
pas d'hier pendant des années les
coffres du pays ont été systématiquement
pillé sous la dictature sanguinaire des
duvalier mais grâce aux pandores rappeur
on ne peut être trouvé une cachette
d'argent qui pourrait aboutir entre les
mains d'héritiers au québec
[Musique]
sévrier 1986 après 28 ans d'une
dictature qui a fait des milliers de
victimes en haïti le régime de terreur
des duvalier s'effondre
jean claude duvalier lui arriva peut pas
de graveur à l'aréoport conduit les
peaux volant fait une bmw blanche afin
de démontrer
jean claude duvalier chassé du pouvoir
sous la pression populaire s'enfuit vers
la france au milieu de la nuit
mais il ne part pas les mains vides
selon les autorités haïtiennes plus de
120 millions de dollars américains
auraient été détournés des coffres de
l'état dont des dizaines de millions
avec l'aide de son ministre des finances
france merceron aux parts de millions et
de millions $ qu'ils disparaissent c'est
merceron lui même qui donnait les ordres
de journaux
c'est au prix du sort que cet argent là
a été obtenu
c'est à voir devrait être saisi et
restituer au peuple haïtien
où on aboutit les fonds coeur et été
pillés sous duvalier est pourquoi les
institutions financières qu'ils ont
recueillies ont tardé à sonner l'alarmé
grâce aux pandora paper cette fuite de
documents confidentiels provenant de
paradis fiscaux obtenue par le
consortium international des
journalistes d' enquête nous avons
découvert de nouvelles pistes des pistes
qui nous mène jusqu'au québec les
autorités canadiennes d'ouvrir une
enquête sur cette question
le long des côtes de la bretagne en
france l'avocat d'origine haïtienne
jacques salesse se rappelle des efforts
qu'il a déployés pour aider son pays
d'origine à obtenir justice
maître salese pratiqué le droit à paris
lorsque la nouvelle de la chute du
régime duvalier a fait un tour du monde
départ de duvalier et voilà qu'il s'en
va et je me suis dit qu'est ce que je
peux faire tout en restant à paris
peut-être pourrais-je jour offrir mes
services pour essayer de récupérer une
partie des photos
[Musique]
lire règne de françois duvalier et de
son fils jean claude qui se sont tour à
tour nommé président à vie non pas
seulement été marquée par la terreur des
tontons macoutes il est grave violation
des droits de la personne
la corruption était au coeur du régime
laifour publique d'haïti un des pays les
plus pauvres de la planète ont été
siphonnés par ses dirigeants dont train
de vie lui était loin d'être austère
comme en témoigne le mariage fastueux de
duvalier
il y avait 5000 invités qui ont mangé du
caviar et bu du champagne
alors que la date des festivités
atteindra les 3 millions de dollars
quand on pense à haïti on pense en
entrevue avec le journaliste pierre
nadeau à l'époque jean claude duvalier a
fait fi des rumeurs de corruption qui
circulait déjà on a aussi dit que la
famille votre famille a amassé des
sommes fabuleuses qu'elle a placés dans
des comptes ailleurs en suisse est ce
que est ce que le président duvalier est
un homme riche
je ne pense pas
ils ont que nous pouvons vivre de sa
main je pense que les gens ignorent tout
à fait
quels sont les sacrifices que j'ai dû
consentir
[Musique]
selon un rapport rédigé après la chute
du régime par le ministre de la justice
d'haïti françois saint fleur les
duvalier se sont livrés à un pillage
systématique de la caisse publique
pour amasser son butin jean claude
duvalier aurait eu l'aide de son
ministre des finances france merceron
d'après le rapport sainte fleur merceron
a autorisé des millions de dollars en
transferts provenant du trésor public et
des sociétés d'état et y siègent comme
la régie du tabac et la loterie faire
des conques liés aux duvalier
france percevront était au coeur des
décisions du régime selon l'historien
montréalais d'origine haïtienne frantz
voltaire
il devient parmi ceux qu'on appelait à
l'époque les super ministre c'étaient
eux qui gouvernent est vraiment et lui
il était effectivement le savez qui
gouverne des finances gouverneurs
réellement donc il a été celui qui
pouvait mettre en place des réseaux
de corruption france manceau a été
vraiment un architecte de
l'organisation des crimes financiers
danièle magloire est une militante de
longue date pour les droits de la
personne en haïti
c'était un des potentats du régime et
celui qui a organisé
de manière systématique la spoliation du
trésor public
selon le rapport ces fleurs france
merceron était à la fois bénéficiaire
est pourvoyeur des fonds amassés par les
duvalier leurs complices selon le
rapport il aurait joué un rôle pivot et
aurait contribué au détournement de près
de 60 millions de dollars américains
pour le parle pas de cacahuètes au parle
de millions et de millions de dollars
qui disparaissent et on voit des
dizaines de courriers signés bertreau
autorise aux touts ces virements
vers la fin du régime des manifestations
populaires ont fait chanceler la
dictature
[Musique]
jean claude duvalier a remanié d'urgence
son cabinet
en haïti le président jean claude
duvalier a procédé au cours de la nuit
au limogeage de quatre super ministre
d'état considérés comme des hommes forts
de son cabinet france bergeron a été
démis de ses fonctions ministérielles
mais duvalier l'a nommé ambassadeur
d'haïti aux nations unies à genève
un poste où merceron pouvait gérer les
capitaux du régime duvalier en suisse
selon le tribunal suisse il ya des fonds
certainement qui ont été déposées en
france peut-être beaucoup plus en suisse
au luxembourg
beaucoup plus peu à panama
[Musique]
c'est du valier
à la chute du régime c'est france
merceron et son oncle qui ont aidé à
négocier l'exil du dictateur vers la
france on l'aperçoit ici accompagnant
duvalier son épouse à leur arrivée à
grenoble donc c'est lui qui va s'occuper
un peu de leur installation en france et
c'est lui qui négociera certainement
avec les américains et les français le
sait vous des duvalier en france
si les rumeurs de corruption circulait
depuis longtemps ce n'est qu'après le
départ de duvalier que l'ampleur du
pillage a pu être constaté on l'a
découvert que duvalier dans le château
de la région parisienne le val d'oise
qui l'avait acheté pour plusieurs
millions de fraude on l'avait découvert
que les duvalier était propriétaire à la
trump tower de l'appartement qu'il avait
acheté riotte qui se trouvait dans un
des ports de floride quand on l'a on
l'avait la facture et c'est rare qu'il
avait acheté une ferrari il y avait les
factures etc etc
les enquêteurs ont aussi retracer un
appartement acheté par frantz merceron à
paris où s'est installée l'ancien
ministre des finances je sais qu'il a
acheté bel appartement de nos quartiers
de paris rue guynemer
la rue guynemer et une des rues les plus
chères de paris
aujourd'hui d'un appartement comme ça
villemaire coûterait
entre 5 et 10 millions $ la rue guynemer
elle vous dira une super de rue qui
donne sur le jardin du luxembourg le
sénat lequel athènes le côté ou
mercereau c'était le jeu professionnel
qui était d'une famille ancienne qui
était à l'aise je n'étais pas une
famille richissime c'était pas une
famille d'un milieu de millionnaire
certainement pas
en 1993 france merceron a accordé une
entrevue à michaëlle jean qui était
alors journaliste à radio canada il a
admis qu'il y a eu des fonds du trésor
haïtien envoyés à l'étranger mais il n'a
accepté aucune responsabilité
alors lorsqu'on est en face un système
pareil est ce qu'une fraction finalement
de cette somme de ces sommes n'étaient
pas sorties n'étaient pas transférer à
l'étranger n'était pas n'était pas
évacué hors d'haïti
certainement je mange ignore combien et
c'est bien là le problème puis merceron
annie avoir empoché quoi que ce soit
c'est grotesque c'est faux et puis je
vous rappelle une chose quand même
régime duvalier a duré 30 ans j'ai été
ministre
alors pourquoi mois plus tôt que les
autres
aujourd'hui jacques salaires restent
incrédules devant les arguments soulevés
par frantz merceron à l'époque donc que
c'est pas les gens pour des imbéciles
que que que que le voit on va gober ça
ou bien donc pour moi c'est
le plus mule de la terre
etc par sottise pas crétinisme et par
une baisse elite est foudroyante
qu'il aurait pris des centaines de
millions de gulu de dollars moment-là
dans différentes caisses publiques pour
la 12 mai à droite et à gauche sans
avoir reçu rien écoutez moi je suis
convaincu de deux choses
kiva qu'il a dû en bénéficier
et deuxièmement qu'il a été
le plus incompétent qui soit
[Musique]
il ya plusieurs haïtiens au québec qui
ont souffert la dictature duvalier qui
ne savent pas que pendant longtemps à
montréal a vécu la femme d'un ancien
ministres corrompus du gouvernement de
bébé doc et c'est avec cette nouvelle
piste que notre enquête pris une autre
tournure
[Musique]
depuis paris l'avocat jacques salesse et
son équipe ont tenté de retrouver les
fonds publics qui auraient été
dépouillés par le dictateur jean claude
duvalier et ses présumés complices comme
son ministre des finances france
merceron bureau et quelques lots ont été
énumérés dans la liste de ceux qui
devaient être poursuivis
la suisse a accepté d'aider haïti et a
ordonné aux institutions bancaires de
bloquer tous les avoirs liés à duvalier
et à ses complices
mais à l'époque les pistes initial
aboutissent à une impasse on avait
trouvé très peu d'argent dans les
comptes entre 4 et peut donc tout à
paris vu que le coach us le grand
problème c'est de tracer ces fonds parce
qu'il ya une architecture financière
mise en place qui rend difficile des
fois nous retracer tous ces fonds et
surtout il fallait que l'état ici est la
volonté politique de suivre ces fonds
dépend de deux ans après la chute de
duvalier un coup d'état a porté au
pouvoir un proche du dictateur le
général prosper avril le désir des
autorités haïtiennes de saisir les biens
duvalier de ses complices s'est
rapidement estompé et je le leur ai dit
il faut vite y aller ou pas ils ont
décidé de laisser tomber que le jeu n'en
valait pas la chandelle au jour et aimé
que ma contribution
se traduise par autre chose que cet
échec et que rire
voilà
j'étais écoeuré personne n'avait intérêt
à le faire je veux dire d'abord le
gouvernement qui a succédé à jean claude
duvalier est issu de la mouvance même
des duvalier puisque c'est à des
militaires qui avaient tous collaboré
avec le régime
pendant ce temps là jean claude duvalier
lui mené une belle vie dans ceux de la
france en toute quiétude
quant à france merceron il a lancé une
entreprise de travaux publics en guyane
et à placer discrètement des fonds dans
des paradis fiscaux
une première piste apparaît dans la
fuite de documents confidentiels
slicks devenus par le journal le monde
en 1992 à la succursale privé de la
banque hsbc de genève un compte a été
ouvert au nom d'une société incorporée
au panama selon la fuite hsbc
connaissait l'identité des véritables
bénéficiaires du compte il s'agissait de
france merceron et de son épouse muriel
beauchamp une québécoise
elle est née au québec québécoise et
canadienne française pro model a été
d'abord les pouilles d'un promoteur
immobilier qui était willie lamothe et
plus tard elle est devenue
et 7 est établi avec france versement
en 2005 la tragédie a frappé la famille
merceron
l'ancien ministre de dû allier est mort
subitement en se rendant vers sa
résidence de paris
il conduit sa voiture et là une crise
cardiaque massive
un feu rouge donc c'est une mort un peu
comme le personnage c'est à dire c'est
une vie de roman aux siens
[Musique]
c'est à montréal dans l'arrondissement
d'outremont que la veuve et héritière de
france merceron s'est installée après la
mort de son époux
originaire de montréal muriel beauchamp
merceron a acheté un condo sur la rue
bernard personne ne l'a jamais vu je
n'ai jamais entendu parler d'elle ici
selon frantz voltaire la communauté
haïtienne de montréal n'avait aucune
idée que la conjointe d'un des présumés
complices de duvalier vivait au québec
je pense qu'elle n'était pas du tout
connu je pense aussi même en haïti on la
connaissait dans un petit cercle de bons
choix ou de délits politiques de
l'époque donc c'est quelqu'un qui a agi
surtout avec beaucoup de discrétion
ces transactions bancaires aussi
s'effectuer dans la plus grande
discrétion
un an après le décès de son mari muriel
merceron a fermé son compte à la banque
privée hsbc en suisse un conte qui mais
un million 250 mille dollars américains
selon la fuite slicks on ignore où les
fonds ont été transférés
[Musique]
l'avocat dessus et sandrine giroux et
experte en fraude et en recouvrement
d'actifs
maintenant on peut se poser la question
où se trouve le reste des fonds qui ont
été prétendument spoliés parce que les
les chiffres qu'on a par rapport à
duvalier et puis merceron sont bien plus
importants
grâce à la récente fuite des pandora
paper nous avons découvert une nouvelle
piste qui nous mène à anguila d'un
paradis fiscal des caraïbes
la fuite révèle que muriel merceron a
fait incorporé à anguila en 2008 une
société écran ap les dolomites
selon un document confidentiel provenant
du cabinet overseas management company
qui a géré de lomitas anguila l'origine
des fonds détenus par la société
proviendrait d'un héritage
nous avons montré ces documents a marqué
ni un avocat canadien spécialisé dans la
fraude et le recouvrement d'actifs
et someone désastre si on vous demande
d'où provient tout votre argent et que
vous cochez simplement la case héritage
c'est complètement inadéquat à moins que
vous ayez des documents à l'appui
ça prend des preuves simplement cocher
la case héritage c'est pas sérieux
le cabinet overseas management company a
obtenu une photocopie du passeport
canadien de muriel beauchamp merceron
afin de vérifier l'identité de sa
cliente
mais selon un document de la fuite le
cabinet n'aurait fait qu'une simple
recherche sur google et dans une base de
données et n'a rien trouvé elle a donc
été considéré à faible risque
il ne savait pas à qui il avait affaire
ils ont simplement accepté qu'elle était
une femme avec une bonne somme d'argent
provenant d'un héritage mais si on avait
fait la recherche correctement on aurait
pu faire le lien avec son défunt
conjoint
le cabinet omc a refusé de répondre à
nos questions au sujet de muriel
merceron dans un courriel envoyé au
consortium des journalistes d' enquête
ou m6 assure qu'il maintient programme
de conformité solide y compris des
politiques et des procédures de
vérification
tous les acteurs économiques jouent un
rôle essentiel dans ces transferts de
fonds beaucoup respectent les règles il
ne reste que certains essayent de 2,2 de
prendre des raccourcis ou ne sont pas
vigilants et je pense que des sanctions
devront être prises
la copie du passeport de muriel merceron
qui se trouvent dans les pans de rap et
plus a été certifiée par un avocat de
chambly au québec m claude leblanc
c'est m leblanc qui a effectué par
procuration l'achat du condo de la rue
bernard outremont pour muriel merceron
il détenait aussi le rôle de protecteur
d'une fiducie familiale des merceron
dans un paradis fiscal
joint au téléphone m leblanc dit n'avoir
aucun doute sur la légitimité
des fonds de la famille merceron
quand vous dites que ça vous des baudets
de da ici est-ce que vous avez vous
aviser la preuve de sa vie vous tous à
lui font
des doigts
selon les pans de rap et plus les fonds
détenus par delmi ta anguila ont été
versés de l'autre côté de l'atlantique à
grünsee un paradis fiscal situé entre la
grande bretagne la france dans un compte
de la banque barclays les sommes dont le
montant n'est pas divulgué ont été
placés dans un portefeuille géré par
brewin dolphin une des plus grandes
sociétés de gestion fortune basé à
londres brender fun et barclays n'ont
pas répondu à nos questions
la procédure de vérification de son
identité de qui elle était vraiment a
complètement fait défaut aux chiroux
soweto elle était la veuve d'un ancien
ministre des finances d'haïti qui a fait
scandale de son vivant et a été accusé
d'aider bébé doc duvalier a pillé des
millions de dollars du trésor de la
république d'haïti
cela en soi est choquant et on aurait dû
tout arrêter appelez la police fermait
le compte bloqué l'argent stop
[Musique]
la suisse a longtemps été la cachette
préféré des dictateurs de la planète
c'est d'ailleurs là qu'on aboutit des
millions de dollars liée à jean claude
duvalier et à son ministre des finances
france merceron la succession de la
famille merceron qui vit ici au québec
se bat présentement devant les tribunaux
pour mettre la main sur cette fortune
[Musique]
en 2000 ans après 25 ans d'exil en
france l'ex président à vie jean claude
duvalier a effectué un retour surprise
en haïti
il était client
par une horde de partisans
mais pour un très grand nombre
d'haïtiens
tu es la consternation y compris pour la
militante des droits de la personne
danièle magloire mais je dus à agnetz
départ en janvier 2011
comme si de rien n'était de manière
parfaitement inopinés et avec arrogance
plus de temps après son retour en haïti
jean claude duvalier a été accusé de
corruption et de détournement de fonds
danièle magloire a assisté aux audiences
c'est la première fois
face à face à quelques mètres la le fait
qu'il ait dû répondre à lège dans des
tribunaux à ezeiza c'était sympa
duvalier a finalement dû faire face à la
justice mais qu'est-il arrivé de sa
fortune placée à l'étranger
6 millions et demi de dollars américains
ont été identifiés à la banque ubs en
suisse
les efforts initiaux pour bloquer ces
fonds ont échoué devant les tribunaux en
raison du temps qui s'est écoulé
mais le parlement suisse a décidé d'agir
ce n'est un secret pour personne
depuis des décennies la suisse sert de
refuge à des milliards de francs
détournés par à des dictateurs
l'assemblée législative fédérale suisse
a adopté une nouvelle loi surnommée la
loi duvalier pour des états considérés
défaillants comme haïti le projet de loi
sur la restitution des avoirs d'origine
illicite est une nécessité
cette loi devrait aussi permettre de
résoudre enfin le cas duvalier et la
suisse considéré que c'était dans son
intérêt de ne pas laisser partir des
fonds qui étaient notoirement d'origine
illicite parce que ça aurait atteint la
réputation financière de la suisse
quelques mois après l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi en 2011 la banque credit
suisse signaler aux autorités
l'existence d'un compte lié au défunt
ministre des finances de duvalier france
merceron et à sa veuve la québécoise
muriel beauchamp merceron
credit suisse a dû payer une modeste
amende pour avoir tardé à signaler
l'existence de ce compte pourtant ouvert
dix ans plus tôt l'amant de 20 mille
francs est équivalente à 23 milles
dollars canadiens
soit 20000 francs suisses pour une
institution financière colossale comme
crédit suisse
c'est une blague comment allez-vous
incité la direction d'une banque à se
comporter de façon éthique à vérifier
ses clients et empêcher des escrocs
d'accéder au système bancaire si on ne
lui impose pas des sanctions appropriées
le banquier devrait en subir les
conséquences lorsqu ils se trompent
le compte des merceron qui contient plus
de 6 millions de dollars américains est
bloqué par les autorités suisses depuis
2012 pendant des années muriel merceron
a tenté de mettre fin aux procédures en
alléguant que les fonds n'étaient pas
d'origine criminelle
elle a affirmé que les sommes en cause
se trouvait en suisse avant que son
conjoint ne devienne ministre et qu'elle
proviendrait plutôt de sa fortune
personnelle et de son premier mariage
c'est à la personne accusée de démontrer
l'origine légale des fonds donc il ya
une présomption d'origine illicite il
faut pouvoir démontrer clairement quelle
était l'origine de ces fonds une
activité commerciale légitime un don
familiale une fortune personnelle à qui
est vraiment avoir d'avoir pris des
fonctions politiques et je crois que
c'est un des arguments avancés par la
famille merceron mais ce n'est pas
suffisant de simplement la léguer il
faut le prouver clairement
le 13 janvier 2020 le département
fédéral des finances suisse a ordonné la
confiscation des fonds d merceron pour
les restituer à haïti le lendemain de
cette décision muriel merceron est morte
à montréal à l'âge de 78 ans elle lègue
son héritage à quatre de ses cinq filles
son condo de la rue bernard été vendue
il ya un an par sa succession pour la
somme d'un million de dollars
sa fille sabrina merceron qui est l'une
des liquides hatrize la succession a
décliné notre demande d'entrevue
la succession conteste la confiscation
des fonds bloqués en suisse à ce jour
aucune décision n'a encore été rendues
par les tribunaux
les allégations contre france merceron
en suisse seraient sans fondement selon
l'autre liquidateur de la succession
l'avocat québécois claude leblanc
les autorités canadiennes devraient
faire enquête selon l'avocat martin
kenny
quelle est l'origine de la richesse de
la succession
il m'apparaît que ce dossier comporte un
risque élevé qui justifierait une
enquête sur le blanchiment d'argent en
bonne et due forme en raison des
circonstances suspectes entourant à la
fois la veuve et le ministre des
finances d'haïti dans les années 1990
jean claude duvalier est mort en 2014
avant la fin des procédures judiciaires
à son encontre
même si les principaux acteurs de la
dictature sont maintenant décédé il est
important de poursuivre les efforts de
l'institution selon danièle magloire
qu'il s'agisse de la famille mer seront
de toute famille de dignitaires de la
dictature des duvalier
la rendre justice et que ne pas accepter
que ces crimes financiers que leurs
descendants puissent en jouir en toute
impunité parce que cet argent là a été
obtenue c'est au prix du sort que cet
argent là a été obtenu l'adage veut que
le crime ne paie pas et je pense que
c'est important de veiller à ce qu'ils
soient appliqués c'est important pour la
justice pour la justice mme toutes les
victimes de ce pays
[Musique]
plus que jamais haïti dans le besoin des
restitutions de quelques millions de
dollars ne réglera pas ces problèmes
endémiques de pauvreté corruption mais
pourrait envoyer un message important à
ses dirigeants
[Musique]
en